boys is she naked spill it pretend she's
invisible
the movie opens with our protagonist
Holly narrating about her life as an
invisible girl someone who cannot be
seen or heard but is not a ghost either
in a flashback she talks about her
pretty older sister Vanessa and her
smart younger brother Troy and how being
in the middle makes her feel ordinary
and invisible but Holly has her mother
Victoria who encourages her loves her
and listens to her tragically Holly's
mother passed away when she was still a
child and with this everything changed
after Victoria's death Holly begins to
feel like she's fading away she is
shattered and the world around her
begins to crumble The Hollies dismay her
own family seems to overlook her with
her father Paul forgetting to ask about
her day even after asking her siblings
and even her teacher ignoring her raised
hand in school at first Holly feels
devastated that everyone is ignoring her
but later she shockingly gets to know
that she is fading away by the end of
the summer Holly learns that she has
become totally invisible in fact she
doesn't even show up in pictures as the
years go by Holly learns to adapt to her
Newfound invisibility now she rents an
apartment in a building that caters to
corporate rentals where anonymity is the
norm she has put up a sign instructing
the delivery men to leave her orders
outside her door without needing to talk
to them all of their payments are done
from underneath the door slipping the
money in cash Ollie has also landed a
job as a paparazzo exploiting her
invisibility to sneak into VIP areas and
capture scandalous photos of celebrities
despite being invisible Holly enjoys
visiting her family and looking over
their lives I wonder how long it will
take for this story to become perverted
later we learned that her younger
brother Troy still resides in the same
old house but has moved to the basement
to pursue his passion for visual arts
meanwhile her sister Vanessa has gotten
married and their dad Paul is now
working in real estate the two siblings
along with their father continue their
tradition of meeting every Friday for
dinner and Holly also shows up although
she doesn't stay for long as it's a
rather gloomy Affair for her while there
are certain Perks to Being invisible
like having the freedom to explore
anywhere and see everything without any
worries about social norms or dress
codes the worst part is not being a part
of anything one evening while keeping an
eye on a couple Holly is shockingly
noticed by a bouncer he catches her
taking pictures of the couple and throws
her out of the club Holly is thrilled to
finally meet someone who can see her and
has countless questions for him however
the bouncer ignores her and returns to
the club yeah I've heard it all before
Move Along towards for some reason he is
the only one who can see her later at
home as Holly is going through her
previous Works she comes across the
bouncer's picture she remembers him as
Shane a guy she had caught cheating on
camera filled with remorse she decides
to do some research on Shane and
discovers that he's a former MMA fighter
and a world champion who once dated
popular actress and supermodel Juliana
however after the pictures Holly tuck
went viral Shane's fans turned against
him his prosperous career spiraled out
of control and the couple eventually
broke up to make matters worse Shane was
arrested for illegal activities and his
MMA career came to an end after he lost
the championship to his fellow fighter
mate de determined to make it up to him
even though at least 90 percent of that
was not her fault at all Holly goes back
to the club and patiently waits for
Shane as soon as he arrives she
apologizes and offers to help clean his
reputation at first Shane is furious
with her and asks her to go away but
Holly convinces him to give her five
minutes to prove her skills oh five
minutes why didn't you say so shortly
after Shane meets with his manager to
discuss an upcoming event and Holly
surprises him by sitting next to the
manager and reading his text messages
although Shane is initially confused he
plays along as Holly points out all the
ways his manager is lying including
trying to pay him less than what the
event offers Shane then argues with the
manager and negotiates a better deal for
himself after this he drags Holly out of
the building and asks her what's going
on she reveals that she is invisible to
others but as expected Shane doesn't
believe her so to prove herself she
stands in front of an oncoming car Shane
pulls her back at the last second but
the driver who had no idea that someone
was standing on the road yells at him
this finally convinces Shane that Holly
is actually invisible to others she
could have proved proven that in so many
less dangerous ways with the days
passing by the two become close as he is
the only person who can see and talk to
her though uncertain of what to do Holly
takes the initiative and suggests that
they might be connected and able to help
each other Shane agrees and invites her
to his apartment to discuss their
situation further if you know what I
mean the next morning Holly arrives at
Shane's apartment and meets his
three-legged dog who cannot see her as
they settle in Holly shares her theory
that she wasn't always invisible and
Shane wasn't always unpopular she
believes that by helping him she may
regain her visibility and ease both of
their lives in turn Shane opens up about
his life story sharing how he was kicked
out by his stepfather as a teenager and
discovered his Passion For Fighting
while defending himself from bullies
here we get to know that though he no
longer fights professionally Shane still
competes in small underground
tournaments later Holly attends one of
the fights but is horrified by the
violence and Shane's meager earnings of
only three hundred dollars for such
immense risk so she suggests that he
fight in big tournaments and earn more
money I didn't think of that however
Shane mentions that nobody important
wants to fight him because he is
unpopular and doesn't sell enough
tickets Holly feels bad for him and
Promises to help him get bigger matches
she then asks for a list of the most
popular fighters and begins researching
them later we see Holly at her apartment
delving deeper into the fighting scene
after searching for a while she
discovers that a top fighter Suarez has
been accused of using steroids Molly
decides to use this Scandal to her
benefit later she sneaks into Suarez's
house takes a photo of his pill bottle
and uses it to blackmail him afterwards
she drops by Shane's apartment and
shares her success in arranging the
fight right then his manager also calls
with the news that Suarez has accepted
to fight Shane in six weeks this sets
the stage for a thrilling and
potentially life-changing match for both
Shane and Holly later during his
training sessions Holly visits him and
they strike up a conversation they bond
over stories about their respective
families and after hearing about Holly's
sister's condition of restlessness Shane
suggests that she might be pregnant
however Holly believes that something
else is up she then reveals that she is
scared of crowds due to a past injury
sustained at a concert Shane is slightly
disappointed that Holly cannot attend
his fight but he has another idea He
suggests that she come to his apartment
to watch it on TV which she gladly
accepts in the next scene the match day
finally arrives and despite being away
from fighting for more than five years
Shane emerges Victorious however he gets
a disappointing payout from the match
due to his manager taking a larger cut
of his earnings on his way out of the
building a reporter inquires about
Shane's plans to celebrate and he
replies that he is already doing so in
his own way moments later Shane returns
home to Holly and shows her his injuries
she naturally becomes worried but he
downplays them Shane then invites Holly
to the rooftop of his apartment building
where they discuss the fight he
expresses his concerns that Holly may
not be real as Fighters like him often
hallucinate due to injuries don't be
silly where do you think the pictures
came from nah oh yeah however he also
clarifies that he wants her to be real
and proves it by kissing her right then
the reporter from earlier appears behind
them and snaps a photo of the kiss Shane
notices him and tries to capture him but
the reporter manages to get away the
next morning Holly is surprised to see
herself in a tabloid photo with Shane
labeled as the shadow girl apparently
the reporter edited the image by
inserting a silhouette of a woman in
there as he couldn't see anything in the
next scene we see Shane at a press
conference with his next opponent bones
we learn that Shane has parted ways with
his manager and when he is asked about
the shadow girl assumed to be Juliana he
says no comment after the conference
Holly follows bones to his car and sends
him some texts to let him know that she
has evidence of him spending the night
with a minor to keep her silence bones
reluctantly agrees to lose the fight
against Shane it is obvious that Holly
is not only arranging the fights for
Shane but also fixing them without his
knowledge on the day of the fight Shane
easily beats bones elevating his status
as a prominent fighter even more however
Holly is not done yet she invents a
rumor that mate has accepted the rematch
against Shane and in no time several
news tabloids publish this story later
Holly sneaks into Mateus house to find
some dirt on him but unfortunately she
comes up empty-handed after this Holly
visits her sister and discovers that she
is pregnant but for some reason she
doesn't want to tell her husband about
it the following day holly is sent to a
bar to take pictures of Juliana who's
seen flirting with a guy to her shock
the guy is revealed to be none other
than Shane Furious Holly yells at him
before storming out of the building
Shane goes after her to explain but she
refuses to listen to him when nothing
works Shane defends himself by saying
that he wants to be with someone real in
response Holly also reveals that she has
been fixing his fights hearing this
Shane becomes angry and shouts at her to
go away one evening at her apartment
while Holly is busy drinking Shane
surprises her with a visit he feels the
need to confess something to her to
Holly's surprise Shane reveals that the
pictures she took of him cheating on
Juliana were not the sole reason for
their breakup or his defeat in the fight
no [__] he admits to becoming complacent
when his career took off and that both
he and Juliana were unfaithful to each
other when the relationship fell apart
due to the photographs Shane couldn't
cope with this situation listening to
this Holly realizes that it was never
her fault she just got involved at an
unfortunate time she then tries to kiss
him but Shane backs off this enrages
Holly and so she kicks him out of her
apartment breaking her late mother's
Kaleidoscope in the process not the
Kaleidoscope the hell is that thing says
Shane the next morning Holly wakes up to
a distressing discovery she can no
longer see herself in the mirror she is
desperate for answers and decides to
seek out Shane at the gym however to her
horror he cannot see her either after
she leaves Shane is visited by Juliana
she jokes that she doesn't date losers
and this makes Shane question her true
intentions he wonders if she would have
contacted him if he hadn't become famous
again the answer is obviously no
elsewhere Holly decides to visit her
family one last time to bid them
farewell she starts with Vanessa who
still hasn't told her husband about her
pregnancy Holly decides to kick the
trash can revealing the pregnancy test
her brother-in-law notices it and
although he is thrilled about the news
Vanessa is scared she has always been
regarded as nothing more than a pretty
face and feels Unworthy of being a
mother because her mother showed
favoritism towards her sister next Holly
visits her brother Troy and watches his
latest movie which she finds quite
impressive when his Crush passes by on
the street Holly trips her on purpose
allowing Troy to finally talk to her
after this she goes to see her father
Paul and discovers sleeping pills and
three pictures of Kaleidoscope art which
indicates that he still misses his late
wife Victoria at this moment Holly
realizes that she has been so focused on
her own loss that she had not been there
for her family who have also been
hurting hence she apologizes to her
father and decides to change her ways
following this Holly takes a boss to see
Shane's match against mate risking being
in a crowd when she gets there she
notices Shane on the losing side and
sneaks into the ring to support him
promising to be there for him no matter
what through her surprise Shane finally
sees her again but so does the entire
audience regardless Holly Remains by
Shane's side holding his hand until
security finally kicks her out
unfortunately he loses the match by a
tiny difference in points probably
because he was distracted by Holly after
the intense match Juliana approaches
Shane with words of sympathy but also
understandingly grants him permission to
see Holly without hesitation Shane
rushes to the hallway and convinces the
security that Holly is with him and once
they are alone he finally Embraces her
in a tight hug Holly admits that Shane
was right about her life and in turn he
confesses that she was right about
Juliana Days Later Holly surprises her
dad with an unexpected visit and Paul's
eyes light up with joy as he sees his
daughter again the movie ends when the
father and daughter share a warm embrace
finally reconnecting after years of
being apart
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching